un brin la faisait des expériences dans
cette ville depuis que nous étions
enfants je pense qu'il transforme les
gendarmes
si nous n'arrêtons pas ça
raccoon city va tomber
nous devons faire tomber un arbre et là
nous ne survivrons pas cette nuit on y
va
secours
merde
barak qui va me dire ce qui se passe
[__] il ya eu une grave chute shane
brennan
nous devons mettre raccoon city en
quarantaine pour que le monde ne soit
pas en danger c'est quoi ce bordel
ce que je veux c'est me tirer d'ici
tout le monde est en danger si raccoon
city tombe c'est game over pour nous
d'un métrage de frais l'accord sur mes
choix pour votre sécurité vous payez
vous prendre de nouvelles mesures
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce porte
d'un lance roquettes
chaque histoire un bon lancement
découvrir les origines du mal pourquoi
tu es revenu clair regarde ça tu doit
nous aider en fait j'aimerais bien il
s'est produit un accident les gens
tombent tous malades nous devons
dénoncer un vrai mais on y va
[Musique]
l'anti renouvellement